gerade hab 379 ps das noch einmal gut
ich habe also ps und zwar ist dieser
komplette command so um die 48.000
zeichen lang
lychen meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer neuen folge der
minecraft romands heute am freitag ist
heute ich freue mich gar nicht so sehr
weil ich am vorproduzieren bin sonst
würde ich mich extrem voran das seit
freitag ist nach dem etwas ernsteren
video was ich gestern gemacht habe zu
den flugzeugabstürzen und so was mich
darauf gelegt hat ist ja auch egal habe
ich ja alles im video gestern gesagt
habe ich mir gedacht dass ich heute die
command mache sowie die halt jeden
freitag kommen allerdings bin ich auch
bei den command setzen wir überlegen ich
bin derzeit irgendwie voll hin und
hergerissen mit meinem kanal mit den
serien und so und ob mann ob ich die
wirklich wöchentlich bringen sollte und
blau oder ob es vielleicht einfach
sinnvoller ist wenn ich die dann bringe
wenn ich lust dazu habe also nicht mich
auf wochentage festlegen dass wir sonst
immer so meinen mein mann mein wunsch so
dass das mache wenn ich möchte aber da
bin ich zusammen überlegen vielleicht
mache ich auch dass sich commands
einzelnen vorstellen die zu umfangreich
sind ich meine letzter zeit ehrlich oft
komme es dabei die mir zu gesendet
wurden zwar von susann aber dann gesagt
wurde ja hier sollen hier so'n redstone
youtuber hatte hier den den command
erschaffen stelle nochmal fordern mit
der mehr aufmerksamkeit bekommt und dann
geht der command halt wirklich dann fügt
am 10 millionen teams hinzu das ist
natürlich richtig geil und ich freue
mich darüber auch richtig allerdings in
seiner folge wo dann 5,1 vorgestellt
werden als ich mache auch diese folge
wieder nur drei weil die alle rechts
riesig sind also ich bin zurzeit
überlegen vielleicht habt ihr
irgendwelche ideen und so ich bin auf
jeden fall derzeit am vorproduzieren
weil ich über das wochenende in münchen
und in österreich bin wegen uni und
freizeit und damit wird mit der familie
machen und sofort alles und da fliege
ich dann hin nach münchen und noch ist
ja auch kommen egal vielleicht finde ich
ja sogar ein bisschen was aber so ein
bisschen real live talk musste natürlich
auch mal dabei sein aber ich würde sagen
meine lieben freunde jetzt hier fangen
endlich mal mit dem ersten command und
wir fangen einfach mal an mit dem ersten
command der erste command ist der
command von minecraft hatte letzte mal
einen kommentar unter das video
geschrieben allerdings hab ich schon
wieder vergessen ist mittlerweile nicht
so ein running gag aber so
running doofheit scheiß mal wieder von
mir dass ich mir in die merken kann wie
er denn ausgesprochen wird ich glaube an
jamie kreft wurde mir zugesendet von
bluetooth bluetooth white blue 2 weißes
blatt so blue so bmw oder place mit
segal und 1 200 x danke ich dass er mir
dazu gesehene meine dann sehr von jay
mal wieder an der gala kommentiert guck
dir mal an link zu seinem video dazu
oben in der beschreibung schaudig dass
auf jeden fall machen wie er das ganze
gemacht haben und einfach sein video
dazu das ist ein sehr langer command und
zwar ihr seht schon drucke ganz kurz ich
drücke drauf es wird wieder eine
maschine kreiert eine maschine so risch
und dann habe ich jetzt gerade hier
schon immer ein inventar 10 items in den
neuen items reinbekommen und zwar dort
nach unten und dirt mut und dorthin dann
desert mountain der 60 und blättert der
sattel und eis mountain 10 und aysel die
gern alles ein bisschen zusammen und
zwar ist meine welt hier schon wieder
mega geil und ich glaub hier kann ich
euch das gar nicht so richtig zeigen
ich bin jetzt mal eben nach hier vorne
kurz geflogen da oben ist die maschine
und zwar zeige ich euch das erstmal mit
dem dirt man muss sich einfach mal auf
dem boden klicken das ist wieder so ein
sport- und jetzt wird hier nach und nach
eine neue etage von dem bergsporn
beziehungsweise runter gefallen lassen
tun und zwar sehe schon es kracht hier
runter wie sonstwas und gleich ist der
dotter und fertig jetzt kommt nicht dass
dort drauf und gleich noch das gras so
der ist jetzt fertig und jetzt denkt man
sich natürlich erst mal hier unten ja
das ist jetzt so eine chance einfach
allerdings kann ich hier mit einfach die
ganze zeit ist so ein bisschen
jetzt habe ich die ganze zeit der sagte
klich vollidiot gut dann warten wir mal
kurz ist es fertig kreiert ist
eigentlich wollte ich nämlich dieses
ding nehmen das ist dort muss und zwar
als habe
stelle mir vor dass es der desert
mountain und ich bin doch schon wieder
so krank wir haben heute unsere
klausuren zurückbekommen und
studienarbeit zum glück 17 drin
geschrieben aber deswegen noch so ein
bisschen herzrasen sorgt und du sitzt
dann an dem raum und einer schreit zur
um die klausuren sind und mel die noten
sind regionale gruppen zu stellen und ja
deswegen entschuldige wald die fehler
mache jedenfalls wollte ich dieses item
nehmen das heißt dort muss und zwar das
kreiert grundsätzlich erstmal so ein
drei mal drei fällt kann ich dir dann
quasi irgendwo anbringen fällt dann auch
runter und noch vielleicht hier unten
dann so ein bisschen einfach so ein mal
drum herum fliegen hier noch mal da oben
bisschen blass und dann seht ihr schon
ist das ganze ein bisschen smoother also
man kann sich damit natürlich noch ein
bisschen mehr arbeit geben dann seht ihr
auf jeden fall dass das ganze so ein
fließender übergang ist habe ich ja
gerade diesen desert mountain hiermit
gespannt also habe ich einfach hier auf
dem boden geklickt dann kann der desert
mountain
dementsprechend kann ich da der satz mut
immer so ein bisschen drumherum packen
dann habe ich hier so ein bisschen was
des blutes drumrum das kann man
natürlich viel schöner machen freunde
das muss man jetzt nicht so gut machen
wie ich das hier mache das kann man auch
alles viel schöner hinlegen hier
irgendwie so blabla das sieht es ein
bisschen schön auf und genau das gleiche
gilt auch noch mit einem eis mountain
das heißt ich kann hier ein eysmondt
machen mit dem eis muss kann ich dann
wieder so sachen hier drüben legen
irgendwie da und diese sachen hier sind
einfach so wenn ich damit beispielsweise
mal den ice halt einfach hinlegen sehe
ich schon das bollern einfach so kleine
sachen also beispielsweise turtle das
ist dann hier seine fläche oder hier der
sonne fläche um das ist aber gerade auch
ein bisschen laut ihr oder kann ich hier
auch mal zu dem desert ding hingehen
kann hier noch ein bisschen was machen
einfach so ein bisschen hat keine ahnung
das ist halt so ein bisschen größer noch
bei mainz will könig an hier mal so ein
bisschen hier blabla
dann haben wir da vorne quasi hier so
ein bisschen was ich glaube ihr wisst
was ich meine damit kann man quasi
einfach berge erschaffen so sieht das
ganze aus ist von minecraft link zu
seinem video zum commander beschreibung
wir machen direkt weiter mit command
nummer 27 minuten warum so freunde
command nummer zwei ist eine sache die
mir wieder von einem user zu gesendet
wurde allerdings von einem youtuber
gemacht wurde und zwar wurde es von von
von von von bellamy pro uk sweers also
bellamy pro uk gemacht und zwar sind es
kreise in minecraft beziehungsweise
bälle
ich kann euch das nicht richtig zeigen
weil es damals gemacht wurde vor
mehreren monaten in einer alten version
allerdings wenn ich jetzt hier
beispielsweise mal trainingseindrücke
seht ihr schon im linken bildschirm ist
jetzt gerade mal nach links schauen dann
werden zwei ringe kreiert und zwar ganz
einfach deswegen hier sehen wir das
ganze command blog gedöns und redstone
kacke und zwar wird ein minecraft
kreierte das hat dementsprechend da oben
dann da ist da ist ansonsten größten
block der kann man natürlich auch in
anderen block neben hier und muss
irgendwo aus dem block drin sein damit
der weiße des klosters oder irgendwo im
command lokstedt drin ja neben den
größten block kann man auch irgendwie
weil sie nicht glas nehmen oder diamant
oder so und dann wird eigentlich dass
mein card dementsprechend so ein
bisschen gedreht und ist quasi immer
wieder auf jeder position soll seinen
neuen posten block und damit bildet das
dann quasi sonnenring und dann dreht
sich das mic art von so nicht von so
dreht sich das dann zu so und dann geht
so wiederum dann dreht so geht so
wiederum und so weiter und dann dreht
man es quasi ganz viele ringe also seht
da werden erstmals zwei ringe gemacht
allerdings da das geht jetzt natürlich
direkt weg war irgendwie der version 1.8
und ich habe es auch in 1.7.2008 schaut
euch das mal an so hier zack so bringe
verschwinden immer direkt normalerweise
müssten die ringender bleiben und so
sieht es dann komplett aus allerdings
verschwinden die ringe direkt und dann
ihr seht schon da oben stapeln sich dann
diese ganzen sachen es fängt langsam an
zu rütteln
holst wie ihr seht ihr schon die müssten
eigentlich da bleiben ich weiß nicht
warum ich kann aber ganz oft hier
draufklicken dann wird man pc
wahrscheinlich durch abstützen
oder es passiert einfach gar nichts sie
habe ich denke ihr wisst was ich meine
ich drücke drauf und ja es ruckelt ein
wenig aber ich denke wisst was euch
zeigen möchte nur in der version 1.8 und
bei mir auch in 1.7.2011 gekippt wurde
dreht es sich immer wieder so hin wie es
da gerade steht das bleibt ja immer so
man sich natürlich einen spaß erlauben
will das vocal gerade übrigens extrem
kann ich das ganze mal wegklicken
das war laut alter jedenfalls fällt
dieses ding jetzt hier so ein bisschen
freunde ich habe gerade echt angst dass
hier irgendwas abstürzt oder explodiert
oder irgendwie was macht wenn ich da
hinkomme läuft alles redlich wenn ich
wieder wollen das den kugel läuft ja
alles wieder extrem flüssig dann gucke
ich wieder dahin who flüssig plötzlich
alles lösen aber ich denke ihr wisst was
ich zeigen wollte vielleicht geht es bei
euch der link dazu seiner beschreibung
mit download link und alle möglichen
cremes drin da unten gehen sie dahin
meiner lieben freund wird so freunde
natürlich wieder weg imbiss in unserer
vorherigen command welt ich bin gebt mir
eben noch ein command block und auch
eben hier schnell einen hebel hier am
wird noch die berge die vorhin kreiert
wurden und jetzt läuft auch endlich
wieder mal ein bisschen flüssig sehe
gerade habt 379 ps als auch noch einmal
gut ich habe also ps hab gerade 418
frames 404 105 300 300 400 200
180 90 jedenfalls läuft flüssig also an
alle die meinen hier geht ja gar nicht
auf ein mac ich kann er gern mal sondern
solltest video machen
ich weiß ja nicht wie viele das wollen
mich hatten ja viele gefragt nach meinem
computer hardware kann man darauf den
zocken blabla vielleicht mache ich mal
oder soll ich mal einfach so mit shader
in fünf cars on video machen mit 60
frames damit ihr seht wie genau flüssig
das ist bei 30 frames sieht man dass er
meistens nicht so gut aber das wäre dann
auch noch ein kleines kurzes video 15
abend oder so egal jetzt vielleicht
baten mich dann gefragt und wir kommen
jetzt erst mal zu command nummer drei im
zwar besteht command nummer drei aus 2,1
mehr oder weniger also der ist wieder
von word engine ihr eingeredet worden er
ist auch in der beschreibung verlinkt
könnt ihr gerne mal schön grüßen lassen
der verletzten stand anbieten und im
video dabei sehr cooler job sehr
sympathisch ich drücke dir einfach mal
auf den hebel und ihr seht schon hier
wird da seht es auch schon mal der red
engine ihr könnt ihr gerne vorbeischauen
und zwar ist es die camping mod also
vanilla modifikation und dann werde ich
hier direkter folge sport und ihr seht
schon command step one of two komplett
pastry second part of the command in die
command block in front of you and
activated with matt stone blog ich
natürlich hier eben den zweiten command
so ist kopiert da gehe ich hier mal
wieder rein gebe den kommentar eines
ruckelt wieder ganz kurz hole mir einen
redstone blog setzte ihnen neben und ihr
seht schon da wird wieder etwas kreiert
und zwar ist dieser komplette command so
um die 48.000 zeichen lernt ihr seht
schon ich habe mir hier unten mal rohes
schweinefleisch und kohle geholt und
hier ist jetzt diese maschine fertig bei
brad engineer click to get items ich
habe hier ein paar items bekommen und
zwar ist es eine camping command mod
mehr oder weniger sage ich jetzt einfach
mal so die berge letten sind echt ein
bisschen komisch aus hessen dazu dass
die sonne untergeht können wir jetzt mal
campen gehen und zwar haben wir hier
einen cooking feier eines tempels also
wenn normales zählt ein kleines zelt und
hiermit können wir das ältere buben und
die anderen mögen rufen
ich mache erst mal das camping feiert
das camping feier kann ich kann ich
einfach mal hier beispielsweise ein
schweineschnitzel drauf schmeißen so
schweineschnitzel hallo rechts und
möchte das nicht auffangen oder ich das
nicht oder
normalerweise kann ich das
schweineschnitzel darauf schmeißen dann
werfe ich auch noch kohle drauf dann
zündet sich das gleich an ich weiß nicht
ob es jetzt an den ressourcen pact liegt
legte es eventuell daran dass respekt
hallo freunde adonai bis wondrak vorhin
hat es geklappt
ich weiß nicht wieso grad nicht habe ich
ihnen was vergesst hab ich den grill an
machen also normalerweise kann man
dieses cooking feier da kann man dann
sondern dieses ding hier halt so drauf
schmeißen dann hängt das hier oben und
dann muss man da so 4 15 10 kohle
draufpacken oder so und dann geht der
grill auf jeden fall an dann kommt ihr
feuer und man brät dann hier oben so
dass schweinefleisch mehr oder weniger
das ist schon recht geil gemacht und
dann kann man noch hier ein smart and
hinstellen dass es hier so ein kleines
mit zum mit seinem bettchen drin
wir haben halt hier sonja soll ja ist
also ein bisschen verpacktes bett die
unten haben wir quasi so ein paar
teppiche einfach diese ein bisschen
dieses laken darstellen sollen hier
haben wir rüstung ständer
beziehungsweise wappen die das zelt
darstellen sollen und jetzt können wir
noch mal ein ganz normales eltern
stellen dass es mich das größte zelt von
allen das blöde ist jetzt das bad so ein
bisschen in dem feuer als mit drin rum
aber natürlich kein ding machen weil man
jeden tag und stellen das ganze noch mal
hier hin
hier habt ihr die richtige ansicht von
diesem zelt und zwar hier sogar ein
bettchen da können uns nachher einlegen
jetzt halt tag deswegen klappt das ganze
nicht so gut wir haben hier crafting
table wir haben hier ein ofen alles
mögliche profil zugreifen können und das
ganze sogar ganz cool gemacht wenn ich
näher an gehe allerdings verschwinden
diese sachen gehalt teilweise also wenn
ich jetzt beispielsweise mal von hier
schaue und mich ein bisschen dreher seht
ihr schon links da verschwinden jetzt
die ganzen sachen das ist ein wenig noch
ausbaufähig finde ich aber schon sehr
sehr cool gemacht einfach so ein zelt
und ihr wisst ja das ganze 48.000
zeichen wirklich ihn gekostet und es
fügt quasi ich sag mal nur dieses zelt
dieses anderen feld und dieses
lagerfeuer hier hinzu und man denkt sich
halt erst mal nur war das noch drei
sachen aber wenn das ganze wirklich auf
48.000 zeichen besteht freunde
in das ganze besteht aus zwei commands
weil es nicht an ein command reingepasst
hat sage ich mal das ist schon mega
krass das ist auf jeden fall command
nummer 3 von der raid engineer findet
alle links zu allen quellen zu jeder
personen die mit seinem command hierzu
gesendet hat oder gemacht hat in der
beschreiben damit ihr euch alles selber
auch noch mal anschauen kommt bei den
urhebern ich bin ja nur die person die
das vorstellt damit eine etwas breitere
masse seht und damit ihr das auch seht
und sonst würde ich sagen meine lieben
freunde war es das auch schon für diese
folge der minecraft commands heute hier
am freitag
es tut mir leid dass ich teilweise ein
bisschen verpeilt war aber wie gesagt
werden noten bekommen dass man aufgeregt
und blabla und es ist auch gerade erst
12 uhr morgens also ich weiß gerade in
der uni und leider komplett egal ich
würde mich freuen wenn ihr das video
positiv bewertet weil es einen klick ist
wenn ihr ideen habt wie ich eventuell in
zukunft diese command serie machen soll
weil ich habe teilweise echt commands
und ihr seht schon jetzt habe ich sogar
nur 3,1 vor gestellt und ich bin in der
raw datei bei 25 minuten also vielleicht
werde ich einzeln com bands vorstellen
und dann nur so vier kleinere mal dann
an einem anderen tag dann packe ich ein
paar kleinere zusammen zu einer folge
commands dann mache ich welche allein
also keine ahnung in welche ideen habt
könnt ihr mir das gerne sagen ich meine
die serie besteht ja eigentlich nicht
aus mir sondern auch die mir die zu
senden
deswegen würde ich mich das eher freuen
über vorschläge und so weiter und so
fort ich bin dann mal weg